in my time of being an anime fan I've
seen this medium grow and evolved beyond
my wildest dreams being an anime fan in
2018 is not only accepted but it is
exciting with countless shows to choose
from communities to get involved with
and an industry that is getting the
growth we always thought it deserved the
landscape is becoming something
unrecognizable from when I first entered
it and I am undoubtedly happy about that
but there have been some things I have
been nagging me for the longest time
about this modern landscape a shadow
that's been looming over that I can't
help but notice and it's not something
straightforward and obvious to points
out so I'm not really sure where I
should be here just a humble bounty
hunter man so how about I start right
here with me which sorry to break the
immersion of having nice aesthetic anime
clips as opposed to my face but to
probably get my point across I wanted to
tell you a story it's my story and it
starts right there in that shed
[Music]
these are VHS tapes recordings of
Pokemon back when they first aired on
ITV and it is the birth of my anime
fandom
[Music]
I like many others first got their
exposure to anime through Pokemon which
wasn't so weird considering how much of
a worldwide sensation it was what was
weird was that I was the only one still
watching it way after the craze had died
out and afterwards I would obsessively
try to look for every other show that
had the same similar arts table because
I was the only one who liked this kind
of show and that's continued to my
teenage years where I would discover
what anime was thanks to the Internet
now I knew nobody who liked anime and
even those of us on the Internet were in
really small communities and this would
transition to my first DVD collection
which actually consists mostly of
bootlegs before I realized that eBay was
not a licensed seller of anime now a lot
of these first buyers came from this
standardized list of shows that would be
constantly recommended by these small
communities you'd find online now that
weren't a lot of us but as a newbie
these were the shows you had to watch
because these were the classics back in
the day anime fans had this unwritten
rite of passage you'd have to go through
before you could pass yourself off as a
real Adam II fan Cowboy Bebop
Akira Full Metal Alchemist black black
black Bible and when you wanted to take
on the final boss you take a deep breath
put on your big-boy pants and dive into
the [ __ ] that was Evangelion
discussions well I'm glad a lot of this
mentality of real anime fans is past now
with a lot of the elitism it bred these
were the shows everyone watch because
they were the shows that were talked
about in the matter what year you got
into anime and that's because of what
the landscape was like back then as a
fan being a fan then meant that you were
a part of this niche community where all
our common ground
was that we'd liked anime cuz finding
another person who did was a rare enough
thing Batman and these shows were
typically some of the best and
well-known stuff we had in the limited
availability we were given we were
limited by what licensing companies
would choose to bring over or what fans
subbers would choose to sub everything
certainly wasn't readily available or
instantly transferred over from Japan
legal or otherwise and because of this
our
approach to watching anime was different
choice was limited so people would
invest time into finding a great anime
for them anime reviews held way more
power than they do now because there was
a higher level of commitment when
choosing to watch a show you didn't want
to waste money on a show you didn't like
and even having torrents was less
accessible than the one-click Instant
Streaming accessibility of today so he
meant way more when he found a good show
the shows were what defines the anime
fandom along with the weirdness and
eccentricities we had being an anime fan
felt like you were in this weird Club
separate from other communities
something you couldn't find anywhere
else in fact one of the biggest things
that stops the fandom from growing was
just how inclusive it felt yes anime
fans were weird but that's the
commonality we shared as a community and
while certainly not everything was
positive things were definitely simpler
so if that's the way things were like
what's changed today today anime has
changed too Lots
well anime shows themselves have
arguably remained the same for the most
part but the landscape itself is
undoubtedly different let's start with
the biggest change that killed off the
idea of the classics seasonal anime
seasonal anime or should I say current
anime has taken over the viewing habits
of the modern anime fandom even if
you're not following weekly it's about
the shows that have aired in the last
few months and the cycle of what is and
isn't current now is like three [ __ ]
days after a show ends being part of the
community these are the shows you need
to keep up with to be a part of the
conversation it's an ongoing cycle that
just becomes our viewing habits the idea
of the standardized list of classic
anime everyone watches to keep up with
the current consensus of the fandom is
dead before I felt like the entire
timeline of anime was always up for
grabs for newbies you had your rough
starting point
boom-boom-boom-boom go do your homework
also don't forget your history lesson
here now it's about what's hot what's
not
let's give everything a [ __ ] try
what's an anime that seems like he could
go somewhere after three episodes what
it turns out the show sucked oh you
[ __ ] idiots why would you waste your
time like that ok this time it
definitely won't happened to me as
creatures of habit we are stuck in this
endless cycle and as can
intuitive as this sounds the important
thing isn't about finding those killer
shows you haven't seen yet and would
really appreciate our big motivator to
watch shows now is becoming part of a
conversation having our water cooler
discussions we can have multiple shows
we are simply content with as long as we
get to discuss it with someone and the
thingis mentality in part started from
something that initially looked like a
massive upside and that is that there is
so much [ __ ] anime coming out right
now and it only keeps increasing ten
years ago we celebrated the innovation
of streaming companies they gave us
official anime simulcast with the same
day release of Japan five years ago you
could just about keep up with all the
shows worth watching while occasionally
discovering something new today
you better be jacked into the matrix
directly absorbing the anime into your
300 IQ brain because no sane fan can
keep up with everything coming out I
can't even keep up with all the anime
coming out now and it's my [ __ ] job
to watch anime you might as well rename
your plan to watch this - stupid
[ __ ] you know you're never gonna
get to these anime is such a wide world
with so much variety in history filled
with amazing shows but when we're
absolutely overwhelmed for the choice
what do we watch we watch what's right
in front of us will you watch what we
heard being discussed by our friends you
log in to the front page of my streaming
platforms legal or otherwise and you're
hit in the face with simulcast new
seasonal episodes currently airing shows
if you're a casual viewer searching for
something new or even if you just want a
new show but don't know what you're in
the mood for where are you even supposed
to start okay did I miss anything from
last season let me see the list
okay what about two seasons last year
two years okay I think I have enough now
to last me through two nuclear winters
should be good everything is available
everything is abundant but because of
this we're ironically more limited than
we used to be but really as much as some
people would take this as her look at
this idiot complaining about too much
anime hahahaha what I wanted to get out
is that this is just a product of what
the medium has become and how our
attitude towards media has changed in
general so let me ask you this what
makes anime special in this modern media
landscape of mass consumption abundance
of choice and mainstream nerd culture as
time goes on the answer becomes
increasingly nothing I think the sense
Minh truly hit me when I started hearing
from several different people how they
would watch anime at 1.25 or 1.5 speed
if they just wanted to get through a
show and hearing that just blew my
[ __ ] mind the fact that we the viewer
could treat our entertainment as a
commodity that we try to consume and
process as fast as we can that's why I'm
talking to you son of a [ __ ] stop
watching this video 1.5 speed I'm trying
to make a point but the reality is anime
is just another form of media that we
consume in this modern age of digital
consumption and we consume a lot anime
doesn't only have to compete with other
anime it has to compete with games
movies YouTube some [ __ ] idiot
starting drama on Twitter again we are
living in an age where time is limited
and choice is abundant our most limiting
resource when it comes to our
entertainment now is no longer our money
it's our time
it's our attention and media outlets
have become very very good at
capitalizing on it there's no longer
that stop signal you used to have
Netflix tells you you don't even need to
care about the end credits
the next recommended YouTube video is
also played by default your timeline is
a bottomless pit you can scroll
endlessly down and as a side effect our
attention span have become incrementally
shorter how many of you have sometimes
looked at a 20-minute anime episode of
thought wow 20 minutes that's a pretty
big commitment maybe I'll watch it after
this short 6 minute YouTube video I'll
[ __ ] even with shows in a modern day we
find amazing it feels like there's very
little chance it'll even be thought
about five three even one year later
because it just gets swallowed up as
being another show in the endless pit of
media we consume
presume cheering shilling resting on the
feelings I say I'm feeling the reality
is anime isn't as distinct as it used to
be in the grand scheme of things as it
has become a more widely accepted medium
of entertainment that inclusivity of the
anime fandom is also disappearing for
the better in my opinion but going with
it is the uniqueness of being an anime
fan in the same way no one really says
they're just a straight-up gaming fan
saying you're an anime fan nowadays
feels less like you're a part of a niche
tight-knit community but more like
you're a part of a general movement cuz
it could mean a load of different things
do you only watch shown in Mecca idols
are you a casual viewer cosplayer artist
animator data entry clerk for your watch
list anime fan means a whole different
thing than he used to and in an age
where we could have something in common
with people like Michael B Jordan and
John boyega
and Kim [ __ ] Kardashian the biggest
difference about being an anime fan
today is this it's not just about the
anime shows anymore it's about the anime
culture the weirdness and eccentricities
have become normalized and accepted the
anime aesthetic is becoming widely
spread it's about that social aspect
that was never as prevalent before it's
about being part of the conversation and
that's fine but I think because of this
we need to recognize that our approach
to the medium shouldn't be the same as
it used to be because I think for a lot
of us it still is anime is no longer
that same niche little community it's no
longer any guarantee there to people who
call themselves anime fans will have the
same kind of common ground they used to
because we are becoming too big to
simply segregate into one group and I
think it's also time we drop the notion
that we should try to keep up with
everything anime has to offer it used to
be that as an anime fan you could be
aware of every new show everything worth
talking about everything that the
community was doing but I think we've
reached the breaking point where it's
reasonable to feel pressure to keep up
in the same way that no one feels
pressure to watch every movie that comes
out worldwide nor do people feel
pressured to keep up with every game
that comes out on Steam a lot of the
discussion around piracy recently have
been around the inconvenience of so many
different shows being distributed on
different platforms but with too many
shows to choose from the starts becoming
less of an issue what's likely to happen
is that the cow
consumer will end up just filing shows
that interest them on their platform or
preference like most people do with
their entertainment it won't become
about keeping up with the community and
the fandom it becomes about what's
marketed the most and what's most
visible it becomes about who can best
generate hype for their products it
becomes as you guessed it like every
other industry because that's exactly
what's happened the industry in the West
is now dominated by massive corporations
or smaller anime focus brands that are
now owned by massive corporations it's
no longer just that same fan run
industry used to be and with the money
being invested into it the companies
have to realize that the audiences are
starting to treat them with the same
corporate standards and expectations
that they do for other industries what I
want to end on is just hammering down
that this isn't meant to be a complaint
about how things have gotten worse or
that the old days were better I love
anime today I love what it has become
and the friends and opportunities I've
gotten because of it but as exactly
because of this then I feel the medium
is reaching a crossroads it might not be
on the same level as things like gaming
or Marvel movies just yet but the medium
I grew up loving has also grown up and
it's coming to the time where I have to
change the way I see it when it was
something small a niche and well special
things aren't as simple as they used to
be and we should keep this in mind as we
transition into something bigger and
anime finds a space in the modern
entertainment landscape anime has
changed the community has changed the
industry has changed we've changed and I
think the time has come that the way we
treat it has to change
[Music]